Trascrizione: Stefania Betti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Qualche tempo fa,
è successa una cosa
secondo me simbolica.
Un’azienda molto importante,
internazionale,
che produce filati in tutto il mondo
ha chiesto al proprio target
di riferimento,
principalmente donne tra i 25 e i 40 anni,
dove avessero imparato
a lavorare a maglia.
La risposta, nel 60% dei casi,
è stata: YouTube.
YouTube è stata la nonna
della nostra generazione.
In tutto il mondo, giovani e meno giovani
hanno ripreso contatto
con materiali e utensili.
In maniera concreta, cioè facendo;
o soltanto con la loro fascinazione,
tramite foto e video prodotti
e postati in tutto il mondo
e diffusi sui social network.
Tendiamo a imitare ciò che vediamo.
Questo rimettere le mani in pasta
in maniera così generalizzata
ha avuto diverse cause.
La crisi economica e lavorativa
in primis, ovviamente;
ma anche, come clienti e come designer,
una certa alienazione dovuta
ad un’offerta troppo standardizzata,
figlia naturale della
delocalizzazione produttiva.
Tutto questo assieme
a nuovi valori - ritrovati, anche -
ecologici, sociali ed etici.
Non si è trattato soltanto
di un movimento dal basso.
Sempre nello stesso periodo,
la manifattura è uscita dalle aziende -
dove era stata rinchiusa
negli ultimi anni,
e resa qui meccanica, e muta -
e allontanandosi quindi
dalla vita quotidiana
delle persone comuni,
per ritornare adesso
con nuovi significati,
nuove tecnologie e nuovi prodotti.
Oggi ci troviamo, paradossalmente,
ad avere aziende che aprono al pubblico
come i palazzi segreti
delle giornate F. A. I. -
per adesso soltanto
in Lombardia e Piemonte,
ma speriamo che avvenga
presto in tutta Italia -
e raccogliendo in quelle giornate
lo stesso tipo di interesse
e di fascinazione.
Workshop di qualsiasi tipo
di tecnologia artigiana
e aperitivi in cui ormai si parla
di taglia e cuci, serigrafia, pasta madre.
Il fare è diventato, di nuovo,
parte della nostra quotidianità.
Ma il digitale non è stato
soltanto maestro,
ma anche e soprattutto vetrina di vendita,
qui lo sappiamo bene:
vetrina di vendita che, nel tempo,
nuovi brand ed aziende più strutturate
hanno imparato,
e stanno imparando tutt’ora,
a rendere più personale, più mirata,
di fatto rimettendo in piedi,
o cominciando a rimettere in piedi,
un intero indotto produttivo.
Il saper utilizzare gli strumenti digitali
legati alla comunicazione,
il farsi vedere, farsi notare
postando delle foto che siano emotive,
emozionali, coinvolgenti
ma allo stesso tempo,
conoscendo tutta una serie di cose
riguardo le parole giuste da usare,
gli orari e segreti di indicizzazione
è diventato nel tempo
sempre, sempre più importante.
E nel frattempo,
l’offerta formativa
su questo tipo di tematiche
si è moltiplicata a tutti i livelli:
quindi abbiamo dai corsi online
ai workshop professionali,
a consulenti nati
proprio da questo tipo di indotto.
Certo che l’unione
di comunicazione digitale e vendita online
ha avuto tutta una serie
di ripercussioni molto importanti.
Prima di tutto, il raggiungimento
di nuovi target e nicchie diffuse.
Io prima, paradossalmente, potevo arrivare
a tutti i clienti del mio territorio
o dove avevo dei negozi,
o una rete commerciale,
che arrivava appunto in quella regione.
Adesso, potenzialmente ovviamente,
arrivo a chiunque possa essere
interessato al mio prodotto,
da Toronto a Pescara.
Seconda cosa: coinvolgimento e feedback.
Il fatto di avere un contatto diretto,
con il proprio pubblico,
tramite l’esposizione sui social network
mi permette di vedere il reale -
l’effetto reale che il mio prodotto
ha sul mio cliente.
Quindi: risolvere problematiche;
poter accettare richieste
di personalizzazione;
ed avere in cambio
maggiore fidelizzazione,
e anche soddisfazione personale.
È l’era del coinvolgimento,
del dialogo diretto col pubblico.
Qual è, però, il problema?
Che comunque dobbiamo farci vedere,
per farci notare dobbiamo farci vedere.
L’immagine è diventata tutto quello
attorno a cui ruota il nostro mondo.
L’immagine è quella che ci fa scegliere,
che ci fa affezionare a un brand,
che conferma la bontà
della nostra prima impressione
e rafforza la sicurezza che abbiamo
rispetto ad un acquisto.
Ma abbiamo pochissimo tempo per farlo:
una frazione di secondo,
il tempo che il dito indice
scorra dall’alto verso il basso
nel nostro feed
di Instagram e di Facebook.
Il nostro cliente potenziale si sofferma,
approfondisce qualità e immagine,
reperibillità di un prodotto, costo,
e poi forse decide di seguirci
e forse ancora decide di acquistare.
Per colpire in questa frazione di secondo,
questa finestra così piccola,
ci si è diretti verso un tipo
di comunicazione "facile":
delle immagini facili,
immediatamente riconoscibili,
didascaliche, già familiari,
quasi pre-digerite.
Non c’è tempo per un livello
successivo di comprensione:
bisogna colpire e farlo subito.
Una comunicazione con la data di scadenza,
già passata non appena postata.
Fra qualche tempo
ci ricorderemo di questo periodo
come quello dell’ansia per la bella foto:
quante volte ce lo hanno detto?
Le belle foto!
Delle inquadrature dall’alto,
degli sfondi bianchi,
le foto da storytelling
con le mani rugose degli artigiani
che lavorano su tavoli in legno,
però con la barba hipster,
del logo che funziona
perché già pensato come avatar,
dell’ansia da condivisione.
Ma in questa corsa alla comunicazione,
e qui arrivo al punto,
quanto del nostro tempo dedichiamo
alla progettazione e al perfezionamento
del nostro oggetto,
di quello che stiamo
immettendo sul mercato?
In proporzione poco, pochissimo.
Perché abbiamo fretta di postare.
Il risultato sono prodotti
tutti uguali, insipidi,
con loghi e foto meravigliose
e raffinatissime, ma tutti uguali.
Oppure prodotti autoreferenziali,
con target inesistenti,
ma postati con hashtag e orari perfetti.
Qui vedete prodotti "carini":
ma "carino" è abbastanza?
È davvero abbastanza?
L’immagine,
la cura dell’immagine è fondamentale
in questo periodo, nell’era contemporanea,
pena l’indifferenza
del pubblico ovviamente.
Ma il prodotto,
la sua capacità di parlare
al pubblico che vogliamo raggiungere
tramite dettagli interessanti
e significativi,
la forte idea che è alla sua base,
è la cosa ancora più importante.
Non possiamo affrettarla
per l’ansia della condivisione,
e del postare una nuova foto.
Se non c’è prodotto, non ha senso
parlare di comunicazione;
e quello che sembra, prima o poi
si dimostrerà quello che è.
Ho passato gli ultimi 10 anni
a osservare, scrivere, connettere,
far crescere il mondo
del nuovo artigianato, dell'imprenditoria.
Dai piccoli autoproduttori,
ai terzisti dei distretti produttivi,
il percorso è stato simile:
un’ubriacatura digitale così forte
da far perdere di vista l’obiettivo
che avevamo all’inizio,
quello di far conoscere ed apprezzare
il nostro prodotto sul serio.
Il prototipo è tale
proprio perché è migliorabile.
Non abbiamo più tempo
per provare e cambiare le cose.
Abbiamo sempre l’ansia da condivisione;
ed è una cosa che ci sta fregando,
perdonate il senso,
per la qualità di quello
che stiamo facendo.
Tutti i prodotti del "Made in Italy"
che più ci ricordiamo,
che fanno parte della storia,
di quello che ci riconoscono all’estero,
che sia la moda, il design, il food,
sono nati da una collaborazione.
Una collaborazione fra designer,
creativi, progettisti
e maestranze dotate
di un’enorme capacità e buon gusto
che hanno migliorato in corsa
ogni prototipo e campione.
Questo mondo rischia di essere
completamente mandato allo sfascio
per un’attenzione eccessiva all’immagine,
piuttosto che al prodotto.
Nel frattempo, creiamo di nuovo
una distanza con il nostro pubblico.
Questo tipo di distanza,
data da un’immagine perfetta e raffinata
cui abbiamo teso in questo periodo,
che però da una parte ci rassicura,
perché di alta percezione;
dall’altra ci fa perdere di vista
quel dialogo diretto,
e quella piccola imperfezione,
che nell’ultimo periodo ci aveva fatto
di nuovo percepire come autentici.
La differenza.
Non possiamo più puntare
su quello che ci accomuna,
ma su quello che ci differenzia.
Facciamolo come creativi,
come artigiani, come individui.
Ricominciamo a progettare,
a prototipare, a migliorare.
Usiamo la nostra creatività
e il nostro perfezionismo,
non soltanto sulla comunicazione
ma anche sul prodotto,
perché è quello che rimane.
Dovete essere voi stessi
il vostro stesso moodboard,
il vostro moodboard di riferimento.
Dovete essere consapevoli,
non instagrammabili.
È pieno di prodotti
che non hanno un’anima.
Foto meravigliose,
app che cercano di dimostrarci
tutta la bellezza
del cambiare colore e sfondo.
Foto tutte uguali
di sfondi di legno sbiancato,
ultimamente colori pastello.
Non è possibile non dare importanza
a queste cose nel mondo contemporaneo,
perché se io ho soltanto
una finestra di un secondo,
bisogna che mi faccio notare.
Ma perché dare tutta questa importanza
soltanto all’immagine,
e non a quello per cui siamo stati
famosi in tutto il mondo?
Il contatto con i materiali,
il contatto con gli utensili,
il cambiare idea.
Perché a volte,
per non disturbare questa immagine
così faticosamente studiata e raffinata,
abbiamo paura di cambiare idea,
di evolverci verso altro,
anche se potrebbe essere la cosa migliore
da fare in quel momento.
Non possiamo più essere
prigionieri dell’immagine.
Questa immagine così perfetta
ci sta riportando indietro.
È importante, ancora una volta,
dare la stessa importanza
a quello che facevamo prima.
Chiudete Internet, chiudete Instagram,
e ve lo dice una
che è sempre sulle stories!
La progettazione va raccontata alla fine,
quando siamo sicuri noi.
Non va condiviso il processo produttivo.
Vi faccio un esempio.
Secondo voi, le maestranze
che hanno collaborato in questi anni
a creare, dagli anni ‘60 in poi,
i migliori prodotti di design
che ci conoscono in tutto il mondo,
se si fossero fermati ai like
sulla foto del primo prodotto,
secondo voi avrebbero condiviso,
avrebbero continuato
a migliorare il prodotto
e avremmo adesso i prodotti
di qualità che conosciamo?
Nascondete i prototipi,
nascondete le prove.
Dovete essere convinti voi.
Raccontare nuovi prodotti,
raccontare prove,
raccontare i primi campioni,
dà sicuramente fascino
al vostro feed, e coinvolge;
ma allo stesso tempo ci intrappola.
Non condividete le prove,
non condividete la progettazione.
Sto dicendo una cosa
che, mi rendo conto,
è l’opposto di ciò che vi dicono di fare,
perché dà fascino.
Ma nel frattempo abbiamo
una rassicurazione finta
su dei prodotti che alla fine
sono solo primi abbozzi.
E la storia del Made in Italy
non è fatta di primi abbozzi.
Quindi: siate il vostro stesso moodboard;
siate consapevoli;
e non siate instagrammabili.
Grazie.
(Applausi)